[Music]
you'll have people come to me saying boy
my you know my high school years you
because i knew you were gay you were the
only person who was gay and that really
you know saved my life that still means
a lot to me there's some really
incredible artists that are living their
truth out there right now and doing
really incredible work like little
nausea demo lovato there's just so many
do you feel it's easier for artists now
to live their true authentic lives it is
i mean easier it is it is more accepting
now
i love that it's just a part of who they
are it's not the definition not a gay
you know performer it's it's oh and they
happen to be that that really makes me
happy
and making us happy melissa's new album
one way out
you recorded this album almost eight
years ago for various reasons it was
delayed what are your relationships with
these songs now i recorded it eight
years ago but i wrote these songs
you know 20 30 years ago wow the songs
are very late 80s early 90s you can't
call it anything but rock and roll i
love the single as cool as you try
[Applause]
how cool are you
on any given day i'm gonna go with a 10.
but what is your vote
well i get to be a rock star so that
gives me lots and lots of points the
song
as cool as you try is really about
you are just as cool as you feel you are
[Applause]